all right you guys ready to do this up
nervous nervous finally back and it's
gonna be the most lackluster return to
drunk minecraft we've already started
that was the intro who is the intro oh
hey hey everybody I'm nervous nervous
I'm not nervous you guys are just idiots
sounds from like full hell what are this
shows called you mean the tape
authorities like the laugh track
interracial kiss I could hi everybody
and welcome back to drunk minecraft that
was literally the intro I guess oh there
it is we are drunk yet what I wanted for
this is world we record this in one
session I wanted you guys to see us get
drunk so everybody hold up your drink
for the webcam wait ahead of you I am
drinking because I didn't have anything
else vodka and Monster energy drink what
are you drinking Bob I'm drinking
bourbon and coke or well bourbon and
Diet Coke technically mm-hmm
wait what are you drinking lion punch
with two shots of rum is anyway so what
the happen here is we're gonna start
drinking and the first one to stop
drinking loses no I don't know what you
lose but you're ready to go dessert oh
yeah drink a certain amount no just keep
drinking till you stop alright three two
one go
oh it's empty so the mod strategy Drake
was dealing my throat it hurt the back
of my throat it tingle back me up on
this I drank my whole class you can hear
my ice rattling ah what I guess I need
another one wait no we barely even
started we can't do that I lost
apparently you're watching this is bad
drug minecraft I don't even know how I
do I don't even know whose season three
anymore wait get back here I need to
explain the game season you should say
series they doing in England Oh
separate TV shows starting and ending at
random time I need to drink more this is
a very strong drink by the way but you
guys don't care you think I'm a baby
yeah my drink was not like the strongest
drink ever but it was about two shots of
bourbon and a 12 ounce glass with full
coke mine's got six shots of vodka yeah
well you probably drinking out of your
giant Batman goblets no I'm drinking out
on my giant mug which i think is a full
liter but anyway alright we are to you
we can hear you the same through our
headphone well you're right be here okay
this game is called everyone who's
watching this already knows the game
calling cuz it's a freaking name of the
game it's right up there above us okay
you guys ready now look up you stupid
bastards
you characters both of the same look you
said it no okay all right
this game is called don't kill the
chicken and the only objective is don't
kill a chicken
okay all the objective of this game is
to not kill the chicken no matter what
we do at the end of this world oh wait
was smart enough to land in the water I
just accepted my hit the chicken no at
the second time I didn't hit a damn time
okay listen
chicken episode ends if we kill the
chicken kill the chicken
don't kill the know why can't we kill
Wade Wade just fine but don't kill the
chicken God we can't kill way there's no
PvP I just started a timer God if the
chicken is still alive after 15 minutes
we win okay don't have way did you hit
it to see how much health flat it had
left did you really hit the chicken to
see how my cell dad left yeah I wish I
could murder Wade why can't i murder
each other
there's no pvp affair see ok the chicken
has defense mechanisms - so you never
know what happen if you hit the chicken
but don't test it out because that's
dumb let's just leave this game God Wade
let's
go to the other Island where there isn't
a chicken and we'll have fun look
there's like a castle over there okay
wait there's a doom chicken I just got a
gold nugget from the chicken
Oh latin goddess what thinks that our
chicken oh my god Oh what the hell stop
hitting the chicken the name of the game
is don't kill the chicken
I know I'm trying to win don't know
don't kill the chicken hey the chicken
escaped hey chicken escapes okay count
we're gonna do this out water water
water water water water
okay the doom chickens got it's gonna be
running around everybody look yeah okay
just follow me we're gonna go to the
other Island because you guys you
[ __ ] can't be trusted near the
chicken I swear you trusted near a
chicken I haven't hit it one oh wait no
you're right you but I you said you
would never bring up those charges again
I'm under water I wish I could drown you
oh my god that's so did so morbid well
in the game obviously I honestly don't
know there's an Enderman over here I
would know that was really don't get me
wrong that was really funny
but goddamn that was a dark joke right
there
what who what was who is that Andrea
Yates is the woman who was in that court
case where she killed how many wait it
was two kids are two or three kids she
drowned or she drowned in her bathtub
huh you see why this joke was so dark
that sprung minecraft yeah these are the
jokes everybody present for you
so go nice what is it mark here what
present it's a book and I got a sword to
go kill the chicken with diary log by
Davis my tiny ship was no match for
those towering waves hopefully my two
crew members survived
hopefully this dreadful storm will be
over soon I've got page one of one of
another
this storm is getting out of control
I've almost fallen off the tower several
times already
[ __ ] climb down tower I'll be able to
go in the basement until the storm has
passed
don't kill the chick why is it chicken
running towards you this is an amnesia
custom story what's with the weird
sizeable journal entries I don't know
fire we'll have dinner yet the fire good
just push it to safety Jesus stay right
no wait can we hurt each other now yes
we can oh that's my Wade why would you
do this no you guys need to leave this
chicken alone you shut your mouth I
released him he's free at sea now who's
in its cage how did it get out I don't
know okay all right here here just
chicken is going somewhere or the
chicken loves me all right just let the
chicken be I have saplings I have seeds
I have apples I have food with which we
can survive normally and the diary of
this guy died battling huevos de
Bergerac so let's go back let's go back
to our home oh wait Oh Bob do you have
another diary page please read it for us
I I read it already but sure read it
aloud uh
how do i okay in your best narration uh
I gotta get the mic closer so I can
sound like you yes please do
this is getting out of control I've
almost fallen off the tower several
times already if I can climb down the
tower I'll be able to wait in the
basement until the storm has passed
Wow you know who you sounded like no
Edward Norton right there wait didn't he
sound like Edward wait what are you
doing away from the fire wait but didn't
he sound like Edward Norton right there
when he was really close to the huh it
was like really good from which movie
like oh I don't know maybe like his
Fight Club narration it was kind of like
that you know yeah after he gets punched
in the face a few times by himself
what's this alert mark spoiler alert
people talking about if you each mark
I have phone um I have bone meal but
it's not working on the trees I don't
see a basement to drink more a lot more
okay
yeah what's over here
has anyone been over here oh oh by that
cactus oh yeah I don't know I I was
gonna try and climb it I guess that's a
bad plan I'm the cactus when the cactus
what do you talk where are you Wade
I went over to the castle the book said
something about a basement that I've
read but I don't see a basement
Wow hey what is going on
I got lodged you got lodged did you
lodge a complaint chicken claim to the
best part of the island I'm going down
in the ocean I see something to try and
find the basements we should make us
shrine to our chicken friend I see
something oh there's something down here
guys we know it's just lava never mind
there's only lava or is it just there's
nothing I'm gonna die I'm gonna die oh
my god I'm gonna die I can't break
anything but there's there's diamond
down here I can't get out guys I can't
get out there's diamond down here no
dope I feel like even if I consistently
believe our episode damn it coal doesn't
help us at all but I found some okay
good for you so what should we like make
tools and stuff or that that's what
people do in Minecraft I would assume
that no ha ha ha
how use your words Bob how should we
make tools we can't seem to cut down
trees I've tried this tree I think I
can't seem to even dig sand so I walk
over near the castle that's how I play
something able to break anything
suddenly I feel this surge of power run
through me Oh beat it with the chicken
what are you what are you tired about
Wade what are you dying about where's
our chickens it's cuz I have a cooked
chicken in my hand doesn't mean that I
killed the chicken our chicken's gone no
it's over there it's swimming it's
taking a bath
it's go my god I broke hey wait stop
killing the chicken wait see this money
you see this my Pig that's happening we
don't want guys I found a thing down
here underneath the castle we should
explore it
what okay I'm not really sure but it's
under here we'll be right there Bob
underwear it wasn't drowning
I would currently be exploring it it's
under the castle like and in the
underneath it in the that part of the
world you can't that doom chickens
giving me a shifty look where bless this
[ __ ] what's in here I'm go underwater
I'm underwater
I am underwater break some blocks like
still can't break any blocks you can't I
can't Oh useless wait hang on oh I'm God
where are we trying to go round it's a
dark part make some torches maybe dig
from the top maybe we should have built
some tools well I've got some wood
there's just obsidian down there that's
bow no there's dirt there's dirt Wow
sorry sorry I didn't mean to hey wait
sorry sorry sorry dude dude dude do you
have enough to make a crafting table
mark I do I do can we make a crafting
table and I think that's a good idea
yeah what do you want me to make give me
so much I have I have stuff to make
stone tools here no I just going on the
floor my sticks can have some oh wait
you give me some of those I'll give you
some okay okay that first drink I took
like hit me in one second wait what is
that what is this what's that that's
what in the in the center in the what's
that it's glowstone you dick how do we
get in there how do we get in there have
you been in there BAM here guys
BAM much work I'm gonna be nice to you
I'm gonna give you these that I got from
the chicken I'm gonna make a hole give
me I made a diamond sword and I'm going
for the chicken oh you [ __ ] way to get
away for that chicken wait wait
also I broke all the glowstone oh that's
right [ __ ] you stay away from those
chicken ow ow ow that kind of hurt no
don't kill the chicken no I'm just
weakening him mark would you kill him
you get things I've got three more
diamonds the chickens dead
the chicken has he actually appeared and
killed me he gives me things he doesn't
give you stop hitting it with a diamond
sword then if you want time for divers
all right you guys have been hitting the
chicken this whole time I want to hit
the chicken okay once I want to have the
chicken I want to see what all this
hubbub is about that Wade I'm filthy
rich from hitting that chicken Bob Hayes
on stir I'm gonna hit the chicken oh no
I hit the chicken it didn't give me
anything
lay into it got a diamond from the
chicken I told you we should hit that
chicken I'm saying this since the
beginning of time you're not a fan of
hitting the chicken Bob get over here no
no we're not gonna kill the tribe well I
live in a society where we hit the
chicken no we're not gonna kill the
chicken I will not play along with your
game it's like squeezing a chicken
around the butt so that it poops out
eggs no horrible we want chicken poop
eggs Bob please no I'm not taking a
drink in like a minute Bob is really
great I'm not doing it I'm finding the
basement whoa
I should have serviced
not oh is it a little stinky their
weight a little potent okay it doesn't
seem to be I don't think we can kill
this chicken it's at 270 health out of
500 what does it even mean it means that
if you hit it 270 more times it will die
what does that even mean well it means
what it said
that's our Bob wait hey no we got would
you like a piece of my meat yes I would
love your meat in my mine I don't
approve I don't approve this isn't
family friendly would have to be I can't
see I can't see [ __ ] that's not family
friend no I'm very much blind I don't
know where the island is Bob tell me am
I am I going towards the island I'm
currently searching for the basement I
have no idea where you are
wait am I going towards the island yeah
you know good keep going okay I'm going
keep going keep going you're fine I
trust Bob but I'm starting to not draw
Bob no oh [ __ ] you guys you guys up here
I couldn't even see you I'm underwater -
oh my god I don't think wait I think I
think maybe I was misled and we're
supposed to kill the chicken before the
time ends which is gonna end in hanging
I get a chick my oh so GOI what I hear
is thank you wait for not listening to
these doing the right thing wait it's
been 15 minutes we gotta kill this
[ __ ] chicken guys it's been 15
minutes we got to kill this friggin
chicken why don't the rules change for
no reason it's always been we gotta kill
the chicken but it's got too much health
you're full of crap
originally the show where the rules mean
nothing and the points don't matter
that's not what they say yeah Wade you
dick
come right to me then no no God if you
can't remember you're not a true fan Oh
welcome to drug minecraft where we make
asses out of ourselves and then better
than any of us we're setting in the wait
where is the chick oh god I got ported
to the chicken why gonna kill you kill
his chicken brains money Bob help us
he's gotta like I'm worried I'm gonna
help
it keeps he's a tough chicken I
understand because really when I talk to
zombie I didn't expect him to have this
much elf zombie went on a different
route than what I had attended wait I
hear the sounds of some of chicken
killing oh kill this friggin chicken
where'd it go I don't know area I don't
know yeah areas he's right on the island
where where's the island he's by by the
fiery flocks and stuff over there oh I
see a faint outline of a chicken oh whoa
whoa I can't see anything
I need to think the universe is broken
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make
another crafting table and I got enough
diamond to give us all wards so that's
what I'll do oh my god okay where am I
now I can't see again this is the worst
one yeah the attitude of this episode
has strangely changed holy crap I have a
plus-seven dinosaur no I just made you a
sword it was gonna give it to you I got
a football games advanced wait Bob take
my sword grab my sword wait Bob we don't
party got a diamond sword Bob I started
the game by killing okay you wait I
don't give a [ __ ] about you I just want
to kill his chicken
I can see all the lava in the under stop
punching him that way Bob no punch up to
me you know always got three and a half
life left I'm gonna yeah
oh wait cos I can't see anything
so the chicken has been slain for now
woot there was supposed to be an
earth-shattering kaboom when the chicken
died the world was supposed to end but
far as I recall oh great chicken Lord
above Oh Great Scott for this for
slaying your emissary well oh you did
what is it it is a chicken statue but it
doesn't look much like a chicken in the
world then did my world I'm dead good
enough alright I think that does it for
the first episode back from drunk
minecraft somehow the TNT put our fire
out
hey why Oh Bob aha why would you do such
a thing
alright so thank you Bob oh thank you
Bob you're welcome they have to hide oh
thank you [ __ ] you Wade alright
that's drunk minecraft well see you in
another episode I don't think I want to
end it that way anymore
well we'll see them in about a minute
and a half when we start recording again
yeah okay we'll see you when I shove my
fist up ways ass